bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler du mythe de
prométhée
vous avez été très nombreux
et de parler de la mythologie dans mes
vidéos et j'ai choisi le mythe de
prométhée parce qu'il me semble qu'il
fait partie de ces mythes qui ont des
choses à nous apprendre sur la nature
humaine c'est-à-dire sur nous mêmes
les mythes ce ne sont pas seulement des
récits plaisant et fantaisiste que l'on
apprend au collège en cours de latin et
de grec
les mythes sont beaucoup plus que ça ils
sont des supports d'apprentissage des
supports de transmission de la vision du
monde des anciens en ce sens que les
mythes forme une allégorie de
l'organisation de l'univers et des
passions humaines
pour le dire autrement s'intéresser au
mythe c'est s'intéresser au destin de
l'humanité
et si j'ai choisi le mythe de prométhée
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils nous
donnent matière à penser sur la nature
d'un des attributs humains par
excellence à savoir la connaissance
alors il existe plusieurs versions du
mythe de prométhée des versions qui
remonte tout à l'antiquité il ya d'abord
la version d'hésiode puis la version
d'eschyle et enfin la version de platon
dans cette vidéo nous n'allons pas
traitée séparément chacune de ces
versions
nous allons en faire une synthèse pour
en extraire les éléments essentiels et
pour tenter de proposer une
interprétation sur ce que le mythe de
prométhée nous apprend sur la nature de
l'homme
don qui était prometteur promettait
c'est celui qui a volé le feu sacré aux
dieux de l'olympe prométhée c'est le
transmetteur le transmetteur du feu le
transmetteur étant celui qui prend pour
donner le transmetteur ne prend pas pour
lui même il prend pour le bénéfice des
autres
un petit peu comme robin des bois qui
volait l'argent des riches pour le
donner aux pauvres
sachant que le nom robin vient de
l'anglais to rob qui signifie volée et
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans le verbe
français dérobés
donc promettait à dérober le feu sacré
odieux et ce faisant il a provoqué la
colère du dieu des dieux la colère de
zeus qui a condamné promettait un
châtiment extrêmement sévère celui
d'être attaché sur le mont caucase et à
se faire dévorer le foie par un aigle
tous les jours le foie de prométhée
repoussant pendant la nuit
on retrouve beaucoup cette idée dans les
châtiments des dieux antiques cette idée
de répétition cyclique
cette idée de perpétuité
autant dire que pour les dieux il n'y a
pas de rachat possible
il n'y a pas de rédemption possible
et donc il faudra qu'on s'interroge sur
la nature du crime de promettait
qu'at-il fait de si condamnable pour
mériter un tel châtiment
alors pour le comprendre on va faire un
bref retour en arrière en des temps
immémoriaux les dieux s'ennuie dans
l'olympe
il imagine donc un moyen de se distraire
ce sera la création des êtres vivants
donc on parle d'une époque où les êtres
vivants les créatures terrestres
n'existe pas encore et les dieux pensent
que créer des êtres vivants va leur
permettre de sortir de leurs ennuis
ça va leur offrir un spectacle
donc deux valides l'idée de créer des
êtres vivants
le seul problème c'est que les dieux
n'ont pas envie de s'en occuper
trop occupé à manger de l'ambroisie à se
délecter de leurs nectars
il décide de confier ce travail à deux
titans 2 frères prométhée et epiméthée
il se trouve que promettait était dans
les petits papiers de zeus parce que
dans la guerre qui a opposé zeus à son
père chronos promettait a pris le parti
de zeus contrairement à la plupart des
autres titans qui ont pris le parti de
chronos il faut croire que promettait
savait que zeus allait remporter cette
guerre ce qui n'est pas surprenant quand
on sait que la signification du nom
promettait c'est le prévoyant celui qui
voit en avance prométhée c'est la visée
c'est le prudent c'est celui qui pense
avant d'agir
donc prométhée epiméthée se retrouve en
charge de la création des êtres vivants
plus précisément des animaux mais il se
trouve que epiméthée envie de s'en
occuper tout seul
il demande donc à son frère promettait
de bien vouloir le laisser accomplir
tout seul ce travail travail consistant
dans la répartition dans la distribution
des attributs entre les différentes
espèces animales
alors c'est peut-être le seul moment du
mythe ou prométhée porte très mal son
nom puisqu'il accepte la demande de son
frère il accepte de laisser epiméthée
s'occuper seule de la distribution des
qualités de chaque espèce animale
alors évidemment on ne peut pas
distribuer les qualités des animaux au
hasard mais pourquoi et bien parce qu'il
faut maintenir un équilibre l'entièreté
du cosmos repose sur la loi de
l'équilibré d'ailleurs le mot même de
cosmos en grec signifie ordre harmonie
et donc il va falloir s'arranger pour
que les espèces animales soient pourvus
de manière équitable
certaines espèces vont recevoir la force
tandis que d'autres vont recevoir la
vitesse certaines espèces seront pourvus
de griffes tandis que d'autres seront
pourvus de sabots on a bear à certaines
espèces de laine tandis que d'autres
seront vêtus d'un cuir épais on
distribuera des ailes aux oiseaux des
pâtes aux mamies ferme des nageoires aux
poissons
et finalement epiméthée s'en sort plutôt
très bien dans la distribution des
attributs il fait en sorte que les
espèces animales soit à peu près
équitablement pourvus
alors entendons nous bien être
équitablement pourvu ne signifie pas
qu'il n'y aura pas des prédateurs et des
proies
bien sûr qu'il y aura des espèces qui
surpasseront les autres qui en feront
leurs quatre heures mais les espèces
seront suffisamment pourvus pour pouvoir
assurer le cycle générationnel pour
pouvoir se perpétue dans le temps et
c'est ça qui compte donc epiméthée on
arrive à la fin de la distribution des
attributs est très content lui très
satisfait de ce qu'il a fait
mais sauf qu'ils mettaient à oublier
quelque chose quelque chose
d'extrêmement important
car dans son empressement epiméthée a
totalement oublié de s'occuper de
l'homme
il a totalement oublié de doter l'être
humain de ses attributs
et le problème c'est qu'il ne reste plus
aucun attribut a donné à l'homme
toutes les qualités ont été distribués
plus aucun attribut n'est disponible
donc l'homme se retrouve nue
trouvant nu ils se retrouvent du même
coup vulnérables à la merci des autres
animaux
n'étant doté d'aucune qualité l'être
humain va se retrouver dans la capacité
de survivre il va se retrouver dans
l'incapacité de se défendre contre les
autres espèces animales
l'être humain est littéralement mort né
et puis mme et m ça signifie celui qui
réfléchit après coup
puis mettez c'est l'un prévoyant
alors comment epiméthée allait-il se
sortir de cette sale affaire
et bien c'est son frère prométhée qui va
venir à sa rescousse et qui va tenter de
réparer les bêtises de son frère
prométhée réfléchi et il ne voit qu'une
solution pour rendre l'homme apps à
survivre pour rendre l'homme capable de
rivaliser avec les autres animaux il
allait falloir lui transmettre une arme
donc prométhée décide de s'introduire
dans le palais des dieux de l'olympe et
à l'aide d'une torche
ils dérobent le feu sacré ils dérobent
le feu des dieux pour le transmettre aux
hommes
et c'est là évidemment que les choses
sérieuses commencent
mais d'abord il faut comprendre ce que
représente ce feu
parce que le feu on peut l'entendre au
sens littéral
mais on peut aussi l'entendre au sens
allégorique
et vous allez voir qu'en réalité les
deux significations sont indissociables
elles sont liées entre elles par une
relation analogique par une relation de
correspondance
au sens littéral le feu c'est ce qui
permet de se chauffer donc de lutter
contre le froid
c'est à dire de lutter contre
l'hostilité du climat le feu permet de
résister aux rigueurs hivernales
c'est donc une arme extrêmement
précieuse pour la survie
le feu permet également de cuire les
aliments de cuire les aliments de les
digérer
donc là encore le feu va être un
instrument de la survie un instrument de
la satisfaction des besoins
physiologiques
le feu va également permettre de se
défendre contre les prédateurs et on
sait qu'à une certaine époque
lorsqu homo sapiens débarquer sur une
terre nouvelle il n'était pas rare
qu'ils mettent le feu à une forez pour
pouvoir se débarrasser est d'autant plus
rapidement des prédateurs qui la
peuplaient
le feu est une arme une arme
d'autodéfense mais aussi une arme
offensive
une arme qui allait permettre à l'homme
de chasser et donc de devenir le
prédateur des prédateurs
et puis le feu il a encore une autre
utilité c'est qu'il allait permettre à
l'homme de créer des outils
le feu c'est l'instrument de la forge
ce qui permet de faire fondre le métal
contenu dans les minerais et donc
d'augmenter encore la gamme des outils
donc si on récapitule le feu allait
permettre aux hommes de se chauffer de
se nourrir de se défendre et de créer
des outils
au revoir donc à quel point ils allaient
donner l'avantagé aux hommes
à quel point d'ôter du feu l'homme
devenait l'animal à craindre
l'animal à redouter
c'est vrai mais
non pas un élément très important de
l'équation
c'est que si le feu allait permettre à
l'homme de se protéger ils allaient
également lui fournir le moyen de
détruire
le feu est une
destruction
transforme tout ce qu'il rencontre en
cendres
y compris tout ce que l'homme lui-même
aura construit
romandie en transmettant le feu aux
hommes prométhée leur a transmis à la
fois le moyen de survivre et même le
moyen de dominer mais aussi le moyen de
détruire et de s'autodétruire
le feu est donc tout autant liée à la
survie qu'à la mort
et dire que le feu c'est à la fois ce
qui protège et ce qui détruit mais ça ne
peut que nous faire penser à ce que
disait freud 2 à propos de dieu
rappelez-vous dans la dernière vidéo sur
freud on avait dit que dieu c'était le
père surpuissant que l'être humain
s'était créé la figure du père renvoyant
à celle de l'autorité c'est à dire de la
protection et de la punition
de l'amour et du châtiment
et qu'est ce qui permet de tenir
ensemble ces deux pôles le pôle
protecteur et le pôle destructeur eh
bien c'est la justice si le symbole de
la justice est une balance c'est aussi
pour représenter le nécessaire équilibre
entre le crime et le châtiment
le nécessaire équilibre entre deux pôles
opposés qui se neutralisent l'un l'autre
et qu'est ce qui fait que la balance va
pencher d'un côté plutôt que de l'autre
et bien c'est précisément le
comportement des hommes
car si l'on utilise le feu avec sagesse
s'il utilise avec vertu avec prudence le
feu ne lui apportera que des bienfaits
mais s'ils utilisent avec négligence ou
pire encore s'ils utilisent avec une
volonté de destruction ya ce moment là
le feu anéantira tout sur son passage
les effets d'une arme dépendent d'abord
du comportement de celui qu'il utilise
l'outil n'est pas responsable de ce
qu'on lui fait commettre
le petit ne possède pas d'autonomie
ses effets se confondent avec l'usagé
qu'on en fait
si on allume un feu dans une forêt etc
la forêt se trouve ravagé par ce feu la
faute ne racontera pas au feu
la faute en incombera à celui qui aura
fait preuve de négligence
le feu n'est pas assignables en justice
mais l'incendiaire est assignables en
justice
c'est la volonté qui guident l'outil qui
responsable des effets de l'outil
et plus l'outil est dangereux plus
l'outil possède un haut potentiel de
destruction et plus il est nécessaire
qu'il s'accompagne d'un usage sage
plus les nécessaires qui s'accompagne
d'un sens de la responsabilité
hélas certains d'entre vous auront
peut-être remarqué que tout ce que je
viens de dire tout cela use sur les
effets protecteurs et destructeur du feu
eh bien on peut l'appliquer
point par point à la signification
allégorique tu veux la signification
allégorique du feu étant la connaissance
en transmettant le feu aux hommes
promettait leur a également transmis la
connaissance
alors il se trouve que ce que je suis en
train nous dire là ne relève pas d'une
interprétation personnelle ou d'une
spéculation c'est le mythe lui même qui
indique qu'en même temps que promettait
à dérober le feu sacré odieux
il a également dérobé la connaissance et
les arts à la déesse athéna et on
rappellera que les armes
originellement ça signifie la maîtrise
technique
dans ce contexte les arts ne doivent pas
être confondus avec les beaux arts
les beaux-arts relevant de l'esthétique
tandis que les arts tout court relève de
la technique
autrement dit de la même façon que le
feu allait permettre aux hommes
d'asseoir leur supériorité sur le règne
animal et de maîtriser la nature de
s'émanciper de ses contraintes et la
même façon la connaissance c'est à dire
la science et la technique allait
permettre aux hommes de devenir selon
l'expression de descartes comme maître
et possesseur de la nature
la connaissance c'est ce qui permet de
maîtriser son environnement en le
comprenant c'est ce qui permet d'étudier
les phénomènes et de pouvoir s'y adapter
les connaissances astronomiques par
exemple permettent de comprendre et
d'anticiper certains phénomènes par
exemple le passage d'une météorite les
phénomènes météorologiques ou tout
simplement le cycle des saisons
les connaissances en physique en chimie
et en biologie ont permis l'invention de
la médecine
la connaissance c'est ce qui a permis à
l'être humain de se hisser au dessus du
règne animal et aqua l'espèce humaine
doit-elle sa domination sur les autres
espèces elle la doit à la connaissance
la doit à cette faculté particulière qui
permet de comprendre le monde pour
pouvoir s'y adapter cette faculté étant
la connaissance
sans la connaissance jamais nous
n'aurions pu étendre notre règne sur
terre
jamais nous n'aurions pu prétendre à
remplacer dieu
son livre sapiens harari nous explique
que nos lointains ancêtres ont connu une
révolution cognitive qui s'est traduite
par l'augmentation de la taille de notre
cerveau ce qui a entraîné un
redressement d'homo sapiens sur ses deux
jambes ce qui a entraîné le début de la
bipédie
or dans les faits la bipédie a permis la
libération des mains de la fonction de
locomotion si vous préférez le fait de
se tenir sur ses deux jambes avec nos
mains on puisse servir à autre chose
or il se trouve que la main c'est notre
première outils
car la main c'est un instrument de
préhension à l'instrument qui nous
permet de saisir des objets grâce au
pouce opposable
et saisir un objet c'est pouvoir s'en
servir
c'est pouvoir l'utiliser comme un outil
le battre on utilise le primate pour
frapper son ennemi
un instrument de préhension elle est
également un instrument de création
c'est-à-dire de fabrication
et c'est ça qui permet de dire que la
main est un prolongement de l'esprit le
moyen de l'extériorisation de l'esprit
dans la matière parce que la technique
va de pair avec l'intelligence
la connaissance et la technique sont
indissociables tout simplement parce que
la technique c'est la manifestation dans
la matière de la connaissance c'est le
prolongement de l'esprit hors du corps
la technique c'est le moyen de la
concrétisation de l'idée
créer un outil ça suppose d'avoir en vue
le résultat de notre fabrication créer
un outil c'est être capable de se
représenter par avance la finalité du
processus qu'on est en train d'accomplir
ça signifie que l'objet créé existe en
tant que représentation de la conscience
avant d'exister à l'extérieur de la
conscience avant d'exister en tant que
réalité matérielle
c'est ce qui faisait dire à marc ce que
le plus mauvais des architectes serait
toujours supérieur à la plus experte des
abeilles car la différence entre les
deux c'est que l'architecte a dans son
esprit la représentation finale de ce
qu'il est en train de créer
ainsi la main c'est l'intermédiaire
entre l'esprit et la matière
de la même façon que l'homme est un
intermédiaire entre la terre et le ciel
entre l'animal et dieu
nietzsche disait que dieu était mort au
moment où s'est effondrée la nécessité
pour l'être humain de recourir à dieu
pour expliquer les phénomènes du monde
au moment où s'est effondrée le besoin
de trouver un sens en dehors de notre
esprit
en répondant à un certain nombre de
questions en levant le voile sur
certains mystères de l'univers
la science a placé l'homme en situation
de se substituer à dieu
en situation de devenir lui même dieu
mais bien entendu cette extraordinaire
pouvoir de la connaissance qui a permis
aux hommes de devenir comme maître et
possesseur de la nature de ce pouvoir
s'accompagne de sa contrepartie fatale
c'est à dire qu'à mesure que l'homme
augmenté sa connaissance du monde à
mesure que loeb accumulait du savoir il
devenait en même temps capable de
détruire tout ce qu'il avait construit
et devenez en même temps capable de
réinitier le chaos
ainsi tout comme le feu la connaissance
ne produit pas seulement des effets
bienfaiteurs la connaissance ne produit
pas seulement des effets objectivement
positif du point de vue de la survie des
hommes
ni même d'ailleurs du point de vue de la
survie de la planète
aujourd'hui capable de détruire en un
clin d'oeil l'équivalent de plusieurs
globe terrestre
ce qui nous permet c'est la bombe
atomique une bombe atomique qui est le
fruit de la science humaine la
connaissance de l'atome
c'est ce qui a permis l'invention de la
bombe atomique
autrement dit la connaissance peut être
mise au service de l'anéantissement
et là encore qu'est ce qui va faire la
différence entre une connaissance
bienfaitrice entre une connaissance
utile du point de vue de la survie
humaine utile du point de vue de la
satisfaction des besoins
qu'est ce qui va faire la différence
entre cette connaissance et la
connaissance tournées vers la
destruction
quelle est la différence entre une
connaissance qui va servir la santé de
l'humanité et une connaissance qui va
servir la mise à mort de l'humanité
bien là encore
c'est la sagesse qui va guider ou pas
son usage
son la bombe atomique est le fruit de la
sagesse
rien n'est moins sûr
elle a manifestement l'air d'être le
fruit de l'hubris de la démesure
cette démesure qui caractérise l'espèce
humaine dès lors qu'elle est en capacité
d'intervenir sur l'ordre du monde
dès lors qu'elle est en capacité de se
prendre pour dieu
ce qui définit la connaissance c
ambivalence
c'est ce qui fait que le plus souvent
quand on parle du mythe prométhéen c'est
dans un sens péjoratif
c'est pour mettre en lumière la volonté
orgueilleuse de l'être humain de devenir
dieu à la place de dieu
le mythe prométhéen annonçant
généralement la ruine et la catastrophe
la destruction par l'hubris
chance n'est que ruine de l'âme disait
rabelais
connaissance sans vertus mènera l'homme
à sa perte
feu ne serait ainsi pas seulement le
symbole de la connaissance il serait en
même temps le symbole de l'orgueil
de l'orgueil qui guide bien souvent
notre usage de la connaissance
le feu et il peut être en même temps la
flamme incandescente du désir
du désir qui nous brûle d'imposer notre
règle
détruire
j'aimerais vous faire remarquer quelque
chose d'assez amusant à savoir que le
feu c'est le seul des quatre éléments
qui se propage vers le haut
le feu décrit un mouvement d'élévation
d'ailleurs lances à incendie on dit bien
que les flammes s'élèvent
autrement dit sous cette grille de
lecture le feu est bel et bien l'élément
divin puisqu'il est l'élément qui
s'élève vers le ciel
l'élémentaire indique la pesanteur
l'élément le plus bas l'eau est
également un élément qui décrit un
mouvement vers le bas l'eau coule et à
la différence de la terre elle se répand
dans les moindres recoins l'air quant à
lui est un élément stagnant il n'est pas
davantage dirigées vers le haut ou vers
le bas
alors que le feu décrit un mouvement
vers le haut
symboliquement le feu serait donc bien
un élément divin
et pourquoi est ce que je dis ça bien
tout simplement parce que dans
l'antiquité on retrouve cette idée que
l'être humain est en connexion est en
liaison étroite avec le monde du divin
et parka l'intermédiaire l'homme est-il
en contact avec le divin
par l'intermédiaire de sa raison
par l'intermédiaire de ce que les grecs
appelaient le logos
le logo ce qui est à la fois la raison
et le discours c'est à dire la raison
manifester
c'est l'idée du verbe du verbe créateurs
or on a coutume de symboliser la raison
par la lumière
la lumière que produit le feu
philosophes des lumières se sont auto
désignés ainsi parce qu'il prétendait
lutter contre l'obscurantisme de
l'ignorance
pour eux les lumières c'était la
connaissance la connaissance par la
raison
lorsqu'on représente archimède au fond
de sa baignoire qui comprend tout à coup
le principe de la poussée on leur
présente avec une petite ampoule qui
s'éclaire et cette célèbre phrase eureka
la lumière venant ici représenté la
compréhension l'éclairage de la raison
au sens littéral la lumière est belle et
bien ce qui permet de voir et de voir
loin de prévoir
on retrouve d'ailleurs la racine latine
loucks dans les mots lucide lucide
signifiant clairvoyant et qu'est ce que
l'homme ni science que l'on prête
d'ordinaire au dieu sinon la lumière
totale celle qui éclaire tout
selon les anciens l'être humain parce
qu'il possède la raison parce qu'il
possède le feu du logos possède en même
temps une parcelle du divin
une parcelle de l'omniscience
et c'est ça qui fait l'être humain un
être intermédiaire entre les animaux et
les dieux en nous transmettant le feu
c'est comme ci promettait avait jeté un
pont verticales entre la terre et le
ciel comme s'il avait jeté une échelle
qui nous permet de nous élever à la
condition des dieux mais sans en avoir
la sagesse
remarque également une chose c'est cet
autre parallèle qu'on peut établir entre
le feu et la connaissance à savoir que
le feu c'est la seule ressource qui se
multiplient quand on la divise
avec une bougie on peut allumer d'autres
bougies sans jamais diminué la flamme de
la première bougie
façon la connaissance se multiplient
quand on la transmet
quand vous transmettez une connaissance
à quelqu'un vous ne perdez pas à cette
reconnaissance
on pourrait même dire vous l'a renforcé
vous l'entretenez
on entretient un feu dans la cheminée
ce qui disparaît si on n'entretient pas
si on le transmet pas promet
notre donateurs mais futile notre
bienfaiteur
que nous a su donner il nous a donné la
connaissance
il nous a donné l'intelligence il nous a
donné la liberté
mais il ne
pas donné la sagesse
ne nous a pas donné la vertu
il ne nous a pas donné sept autres
propriétés des dieux qui permet de
maîtriser la première
qui permet de maîtriser la connaissance
récent de constater que dans la plupart
des récits mythologiques
à chaque fois que l'être humain accède à
une faculté des dieux il en est toujours
puni
que se passe-t-il dans l'épisode
biblique d'adam et eve il se passe que
lorsque adam et eve gouttes du fruit de
l'arbre de la connaissance du bien et du
mal
ce fruit dont le serpent a bien dit
qu'après l'avoir goûtée adam et eve
serait semblable aux dieux
après avoir transgressé c'est interdit
autrement dit après avoir accédé à la
connaissance adam et eve sont punis
sont expulsés du jardin d'éden et se
voit contraint d'expérimenter les lois
de la matière
expérimenté le travail et la souffrance
rendu compte que prométhée avait dérobé
le feu sacré
il n'a pas simplement puni promettait
ce n'est pas seulement prométhée qui l'a
condamné à une souffrance perpétuelle
il a également décidé de punir le règne
humain dans son ensemble
c'est pour cette raison qu'il a faits
créée par héphaïstos la première femme
humaine pandore littéralement celle qui
est ornée de tous les dons
d'aphrodite elle reçut la beauté
d'apollon le talent musical
eynaud l'habileté technique
ceux là
curiosité et l'art du mensonge
aydius offrit pandore à epiméthée
damman epiméthée ne pouvait que
succomber à la beauté fatale de pandore
mais il se trouve que pandore apporte
avec elle une boîte la fameuse boîte de
pandore que zeus lui avait interdit
d'ouvrir
et une fois mariée à epiméthée pandore
tiraillé par la curiosité qu'elle avait
reçu d'hermès ne put s'empêcher d'ouvrir
la boîte
or cette boîte contenait tous les
malheurs de l'humanité
la maladie
m la vieillesse
amine et l'espérance en ouvrant
boîte à pandore libera tous les maux de
l'humanité
lorsqu'elle voulu refermer la boîte elle
comprit qu'il était déjà trop tard
chose qui reste à hofu de la boîte de
pandore
c'est l'espérance
l'espérance le plus grand de tous les
maux le mal qui nous fait supporter
les autres mondes
[Musique]
dans l'olympe l'harmonie qui régnait
jadis vacille zeus a détrôné son père
chronos et s'est emparé du pouvoir
prométhée le titan et son frère et puis
mettez se sont ralliés à zeus qui
devient ainsi le dieu suprême de
l'olympe
un matin fomentant un projet cher à son
coeur
zeus convoque les deux frères et leur
dit je vous ordonne décret la vie sur
terre les hommes et les animaux et de
leur octroyer les dons et qualité dont
ils auront besoin pour vivre
et il ajouta à thouars prométhée tu te
confie la charge de donner le souffle de
la vie à chaque être est à toi epiméthée
de les armer pour se défendre
epiméthée demande à son frère de le
laisser seul crée les êtres vivants
prométhée accepte impulsif le titan
commence par les animaux sans réfléchir
il répartit aussitôt tous les dons la
force la rapidité le courage et la ruse
les plumes et poils pour se protéger du
froid
puis quand vient enfin le tour des
hommes il ne reste plus rien epiméthée
dont le nom signifie qui réfléchit trop
tard se trouvent démunis ne sachant pas
comment réparer son erreur il appelle
son frère allaitent prométhée voit les
animaux féroces puis se tourner vers les
hommes ils sont nus sans arme
sans aucune protection il comprend
qu'ils n'auront aucune chance de
survivre dans ce monde sauvage plus sage
et avisé que son frère prométhée le prix
voyant réfléchi et si nous allons mettre
les hommes debout à l'image des dieux et
surtout nous allons leur donner ce qui
le rendra supérieur aux animaux la
connaissance je leur transmets très mons
avoir reçu d'athéna déesse de la sagesse
avec de l'eau et de la terre prométhée
façonnent le corps des hommes
athena lui a enseigné la métallurgie les
arts et les techniques agricoles
prométhée leur transmet ses
connaissances ne reste plus que le feu
nécessaire pour sauver l'humanité avec
les hommes pourront fabriquer des outils
construire un habitat chasse et élever
des animaux cuir se vêtir se réchauffer
avec le feu les hommes pourront
soumettre la nature hostile et survivre
mais le feu n'existe alors qu'en un seul
endroit
nos lampes où vivent les dieux il faudra
le l'or volé prométhée prix athéna de le
faire entrer secrètement elle accepte
une fois sur place ils dérobent un tison
de feu sacré qu'il dissimule dans une
tige de roseaux puis il offre aux hommes
voici le feu prenez en soin il sera
votre meilleure protection
mais bientôt deux s'aperçoit du vol de
prométhée et sa colère est sans limite
élaborant sa vengeance il leur donne la
création de pandore première femme morte
elle sur terre et offre sa main
epiméthée celle ci apporte avec elle
deux boîtes qui une fois ouverte libère
tous les maux de l'humanité
le châtiment réservé à prométhée est
tout aussi cruel prométhée comment as-tu
osé bafouer l'interdît tu as volé le feu
sacré des dieux tu as cru être mon égal
mais tu n'es qu'un titan ton châtiment
sera à la hauteur de ton crime d'une
voix blanche et froide
il ordonne héphaïstos dieu du feu emmène
promettait dans les montagnes du caucase
et enchaîne le a empoché qu'un aigle
vienne lui dévorer le foie et que ce
châtiment se répète pour l'éternité
soumis au supplice de dieu prométhée est
condamné à rester enchaîné au rocher
chaque jour d'un battement d'aile
l'aigle vient et fond sur sa proie pour
se rassasier de son foie et chaque nuit
dans l'obscurité immobile l'organe se
régénère mais le rapace revient toujours
au petit matin pour son effroyable
festin
[Musique]
merci prométhée